Okay, so last but not least for this introductory class from Real, we've got IES profiles.
So we're going to take a look at what is an IES profile as well as how to set it up.
So the Illuminating Engineering Society defined a file format which describes
the light distribution for a light source based on light source data from real-world measurements.
The IES profile is a lighting industry standard which allows you to diagram the brightness and
the falloff of the light as it exists in a particular real-world light fixture.
Now the cool thing is that we can grab this in Unreal and make it drive the light distribution
of the light that we have. So how do we do this? It's really simple, we just go to the
light profile section of the light in the details panel and assign one. So let's go ahead and do
that real quick in the engine. So I'm going to bring in a spotlight here and you can see by default
we just have a very basic shape on our light. I'm going to increase the intensity so we can
see it really really clearly. So you can see there, pretty standard light setup right. Now if
I go to the profile section, if I scroll down, I've got an IES texture I can use. If I scroll
down here I can use one of the ones that are pre-made here. So let's go ahead and look at
Complex IES. So you can see that's now changed the way that this light is distributed.
Let's take a look at it from a slightly more obvious point of view if we put it next to a wall
like this where we can really see what the light is doing. So you can see very simple
there and if we go back to that Complex IES you can see the change in the lighting distribution
and that's down to that IES profile. I'm going to bring the intensity down so we can see a bit
more clearly but you can see it's changed the distribution of the light and again you can just
play around with these. You can also download them from a particular manufacturer and
put them in yourself. So a really nice tool that you have here to try and replicate,
that will help you replicate a particular light and set up some fixtures
based on real-world measured data.